hello everybody how's everybody doing
I hope you're doing just fine today I
was going to talk about the existence of
time but I have to apologize I'm gonna
be postponing that till Wednesday
instead some other issues came up which
I thought I couldn't let go by so I'm
gonna talk about a couple things I've
been talking about which is infinity
what a straight line is and basically a
common couple comments made about black
holes which really that people have a
gross misconception of what a black hole
is and I mentioned that I think it was
last time or the time before that when I
was on jf jeeze program jf Goretti and
and he also made the same error he
thought a a black hole was some kind of
ball some black ball small about black
ball maybe a tiny little eat cbt ball I
want to make sure we clarify today that
a black hole is zero dimensional has no
size no diameter no volume okay it's
it's nothing so that's what I want to
get to today I want to make sure that's
clear yay so that we don't fool around
with with this black ball deal like the
black hole is not a black ball it's a
hole otherwise they would have called it
a black ball anyways let's begin with
the first question or the first issue
that was brought up and here it is okay
and the fella says lines of electric
force extend to infinity
they cannot abruptly end in space you
cannot measure infinity you can eat but
you can rationalize upon and perceive it
I don't know how you compare the lines
of force between two the plates of a
condenser can make this self-evident
okay that's what the fellow put in there
how do we answer that well first of all
here we have side by side so we can
follow along
you know I would ask the fellow if he's
ever bitten to infinity I mean where is
it Vinny what is infinity and instead
you know and yeah you know it'd be nice
if he could rationalize it for us and a
good place to start is by defining
infinity you know absolutely perfectly
you know unambiguously rigorously that's
what he's got to do it he's got to
define what the word infinity means and
any other issue it says lines between
plates well if anything is between any
two things for sure it's not infinite
okay and even the Aristotle told us that
and here you see a picture of that of
lines of force between two plates on a
condenser and you know begin the blinds
a force begin there and there so there's
no infinity about it and you'll find
other similar pictures on the internet
so you know this guy's got to clarify
what he means by infinite if it's going
to be between anything between two
objects so no lines of force are not
infinite meaning and he says they cannot
end in space and there we agree because
space is not a physical object that's
why it cannot end in space they end in
another atom they don't go to infinity
the the fact that you didn't trace it to
where it ends doesn't mean that it goes
to infinity it means it goes to another
atom because it's a the lines of force
or threads of the rope and that's why
they don't go to infinity they stop it
in at the next atom down the road or one
partner down okay uh here's another
issue that was brought up and this one
looks kind of funny also straight line
on a sphere a straight line on a sphere
yeah you heard it right referred to as a
geodesic a Pierce curve but it is
actually straight you know these people
swallow all kinds of word wizardry from
the mathematicians you can tell them
anything and they'll just repeat it they
don't even know what they're saying you
know I want you to take
a straight ruler gay or as straight as
you possibly get one right yeah I mean
obviously it's got some imperfections
and I want you to lay it anywhere you
want you got a choice you can land
anywhere you want on a basketball okay
that's pretty round also and I want you
to see if there if if it matches the
curved surface of the basketball
anywhere okay and I don't think you can
do that and so what they did what they
did they converted the so called line
remember when a line is according to
Aristotle you know they don't talk about
geom geometric lines what they talk
about is itineraries and so they said
well you know I always went forward so I
went straight but they went on a curve
and he caught straight and because
they're talking about motion they're not
talking they're talking about the
shortest distance meaning shortest
distance traveled along the surface they
call that a geodesic and they say that
it's straight no no it's not straight
because straight is an adjective you can
only apply it to objects I itinerary
along the surface of a ball is not a
physical object it's a verb and so you
can only qualify it with AdWords you
can't say straight trajectory not in
physics may be an ordinary speech and
mathematics and all those religions you
can say whatever you want but in physics
you cannot straight
say straight trajectory straight
itinerary straight orbit or whatever
straight motion no such thing it's
linear that's the correct word because
you are moving rectilinear Li meaning
that it's an adverb your qualifying
motion inner or curvilinear unions and
say curve in linearly as well that
you're moving in a curve okay so you
know the the geodesic is not a straight
line only in mathematics do they call it
straight line and here you have a
a little article from the Wikipedia and
it's got to do with this what is known
as the Great Circle it says the Great
Circle distance is the shortest distance
between two points again they're talking
about not just distance but distance
travel they're talking about motion
along the surface of a sphere okay
between two points on the surface of a
sphere measured along the surface of the
sphere as opposed to a straight line
through the spheres interior okay
because then yes you can go in a
straight line if you can go through the
spheres interior right the distance
between two points in a Euclidean space
is the length of a straight line between
them but on the sphere there are no
straight lines so what is this all
talking about a straight line on a
sphere in spaces with curvature straight
lines are replaced by geodesics okay so
what they do is again you know they're
doing work wizardry they're saying look
we're gonna call it a geodesic I'm gonna
say it's straight grid geodesic meaning
straight line motion along the curve
what is that what not what is that what
is nonsense is that
that's just word wizardry that's all it
is if you define the word straight and
the word curved rigorously then you
won't have a problem
but of course if you use these words any
way you want and you go back and forth
and you say well under the fourth
dimension it's a straight line and
nonsense like that well yeah then you
know you can run around forever because
no one can object to what you're saying
because no one understands your language
because you're you're moving the
goalposts you're changing everything as
we go along okay so now keep that in
mind a lot of that is word wizardry and
nothing but okay and here we had a
fellow talked about black holes and
that's the issue I want to get to today
bill gets hung up about singularity
being zero dimensional but think of it
as a representative point which will
account for the gravitational strength
of the collapsed star much like the
point in the middle of Earth
representing its gravitational probe
pull well we're not
about a point like a dot two-dimensional
dot and we're talking about the center
of mass or the center of location that's
what it is it's a location where you can
maybe draw lines to it or whatever
equidistance center type of thing so a
center is not a dot is that a point but
when you use the word point again its
word wizardry because you can use the
word point as a location or as a dot and
so they're talking about singularity
what is a singularity you know and and
if you call it a point what do you mean
by point are you saying it's a physical
object is a geometric figure is that
what you're referring to or are you just
saying that a point is a location you
know these things need to be clarified
and and so here's my reply to that ok
side by side again you know as the point
zero D in fact according to Euclid it is
zero D in fact the Mathemagician stood a
continue to say that it's zero D but
what do they mean by zero D they don't
mean that it's got length width and
height it has nothing to do with that
they say that you don't need any
coordinates as they call it
meaning number lines to locate it on a
Cartesian coordinate system that's what
they mean so it's all twisted around
okay we're not talking physics we're
talking mathematics that's what we're
talking there when we say point okay so
the point is very misleading because you
really got to know what you're talking
about are you talking about physics are
you talking about a dot are you talking
about a little ball which is what this
is gonna lead to okay we're talking
about a black hole and they're gonna
call it a point of singularity and
that's very misleading because that word
singularity like the word point you know
it can mean two things it could mean a
little ball it can mean a little hole
that's got no volume no no diameter no
radius no size no anything there's
nothing there and then gravitational
strength is the concept
okay so you cannot say that you're gonna
do something with a gravitational
strength
yeah there's no such physical standalone
object so you can't use that too
depict the singularity or vice-versa
use a point a dot to represent the
gravitational strength okay because
that's like putting a heart to represent
love then you got the center-of-mass
point again is not a thing okay not an
object's not a body and so is point a
dot or a location that's what the person
has to answer you know are you talking
physics are you talking mathematics
okay so that this is where the hang-up
comes in the hang-up is that they do not
use their words consistently and they
never will because they need because
they're gonna talk about physics and
gonna describe it with words that they
miss defined or never defined in
mathemagics then we got a problem
because you know you can't put put them
against the ropes you can't pin him
against the ropes because the guy who
easels around he says well now I'm
talking about math well then math is not
the language of physics okay don't don't
bring your math language into physics
okay because in physics it's got to be
straightforward you're talking about an
object you're talking about a concept
you're talking about a concept get out
go back to math okay so now don't bring
the word point to them big don't bring
the word singularity because they have
no meaning in physics there's no such
thing body entity diameters radius and
the I don't know that I stay the lone
object that is zero dimensional yeah
that it has no size okay so this vowel
then defines a singularity for us thank
God okay
singularity here's a definition in
scientific terms okay finally we get
science here okay and let's see a
gravitational singularity or spacetime
singularity is a location blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah location turns a
singularity is a location is that a
physical object and you say that is that
a location moves a star around
is that what US location does it's a
standalone location nothing there is
just location whatever that means and
and it moves
stars around as general relativity holds
that you have the singularity
affects stars far away not only does it
move them around I can orbit around
themselves but also withdraws some of
the gas from its skin how does it do
that I want to I want to you to explain
the mechanism how does a location do it
so yeah if it's a location well you know
it's a set a standalone object and you
cannot say that a location does this and
the location does that that interfaces
with matter especially with a star so we
got a problem with a word location used
in that sense I mean if it's a location
so far you haven't put anything in that
location until you do you can't do
physics that's the point okay okay and
so he continues he says he says black
hole is predominantly a collapsed star
such as the mass as that the mass has
been compressed to a small size this is
where we have a serious problem okay
the most accurate representation would
be a black ball black ball is that what
a black hole is a ball a sphere perfect
sphere I guess right because it's
compressed Slovenia so it's gotta be
very close to perfect it's compact
remember it's completely compact so it's
like a tiny ball right that's what he's
suggesting here the black hole has
dimensions of a dust I guess three of
them one of which is the swatched
Schwarzschild radius which is this is
not the black hole but the gravitational
radius beyond which light cannot escape
so he defeats his own argument he says
the black hole has dimensions one of
which is a soir style radius but this is
not the black hole and so he's gonna
teach me a little bit so thank God
because I'm gonna learn something today
he says to help Bill understand the
black hole we have the following
pictorial representation oh I'm so glad
he did this you know because otherwise
I'd remain in the dark you know and so
he points to this loony here this fellow
his name is Derek Muller and he just
spreads a lot of garbage around from
quantum mechanics and relativity without
analyzing it critically he just spits
out the
party-line that's all he does he's just
some recites and so this gullible nut
numbskull right and he what does he do
he puts a black ball there you can see
the black ball inside the black circle
and then you have the white ring which
is the matter floating around the black
hole supposedly so the extent of that
black circle is the extent of the sphere
of influence of the black ball which
apparently right or supposedly has a lot
of mass concentrated in it okay so
they're saying it not only has mass it's
got matter because that black ball has
matter obviously that's what they're
suggesting so it got matter just
compressed matter it weighs a lot it has
a lot of mass and because of that it has
a sphere of influence that extends all
the way to where the white circle starts
on the inside right and so what happens
is that what a black hole is is that
what everybody out there in the world
especially in the world of math
understands by a black hole so we have a
star right let's keep in mind here what
the context is we have a star big star
bigger than the Sun we don't care how
big it is it's just big and it's going
to compress you know it's gonna compress
all the matter all the hydrogen atoms
all the helium atoms all there and
everything it's made throughout its
lifetime right it's gonna compress it
and it's not gonna go to zero it's gonna
go and stop for whatever reasons at the
black ball and we don't care about the
size of the black ball because so far we
have something that's three dimensional
it could be this little could be this
big could be the size of a basketball we
don't care the point is they're saying
it doesn't collapse to zero okay this is
what this guy is saying this both him
and the guy that he reference okay
that's that's what they're saying okay
let's bring some evidence that spring
proof game and here we have the first
one yay and this is for from a PhD
teaching at the University of Toronto
and he says the following
if the mass of the star is greater than
about three solar masses three times the
Sun right it goes through the neutron
stage and keeps collapsing in this case
the gravitational attraction is so
intense the neutrons are literally
crushed out of existence out of
existence we call the object a black
hole I characterize the black hole as an
object whose gravitational pressure is
so intense that the matter of the object
is crushed out of existence now I don't
know what you understand by out of
existence it doesn't seem like there's
nothing there anymore it's like you know
we don't have length width and height
anymore he encrusted out of existence I
mean that's what I understand I don't
know if you understand something
different okay just in case let's keep
going let's find out here is another
fellow okay and he said he's also a
teacher a professor at the University of
Maryland a black hole is a region a
region what do you mean a region I
thought it was a ball it's a region the
same thing as a ball
I mean region is a concept but black
ball is a standalone object okay these
people don't seem to tell the difference
for them it's the same thing the region
is the same thing in fact
TFG toby and region is a physical object
as far as he was concerned so we got a
problem because region is always of
something else region is a region of
your hand like the palm is a region of
your hand right region is always of
something else in this case region of so
called space which they treat is a
physical object so they say look you got
this body out there called space and
we're going to take a region of it and
that's gonna be a black ball is that is
that a fair assessment okay so that's
the context here it's got nothing to do
with physics got to do with a lot of
magic mathematics okay region of space
in which the matter is so compact that
nothing can escape from it not even
light the surface of a black hole inside
of which nothing can escape is called an
event horizon so it's got a surface
right yeah so we're talking about a
surface then he says the matter that
forms a black hole is crushed out of
existence so what is the surface of if
the
matter is crushed out of existence and
just in case you make sure you
understood
just as the chest our cat disappeared
and left only a smile behind ok smile is
a physical object a black hole
represents matter that leaves only its
gravity behind gravity is a concept so
if the star collapsed to the point where
only left its gravity behind there is
nothing there all we have is a console
we have is love we have information I
don't know we have a lot of concepts
what we don't have is a ball we don't
have a black ball a three-dimensional
ball ok and so here I put it this is a
black hole that's what it looks like
exactly like that I hope you see it ok
reach above influence event horizon
surrounding a zero dimensional zero size
zero' volume nothing singularity ok so
that's what a black hole is nothing that
the mathematicians use to explain why
stars revolve around nothing and and
they ask the astronomer because those
are theoretical physicists right
so-called physicists and what they do is
they tell the asylum ORS go look for it
go look for nothing
yay I went as nothing looked like well
go find it I'll tell you
ok here we have another one ok and this
one says it's not the size of again this
guy's a PhD ok I'm only got PhDs because
I want to make sure we have the proper
authority behind this ok because they're
gonna say well you got this wrong who
knows who now these guys are PhDs in
so-called physics
ok and their teachers at universities ok
so I'm not talking about just bozos that
make $2 an hour ok here ok it's not the
size of a pinhead but actually has zero
size has zero size now zero size how
many dimensions that set have is that
have three dimension length width and
height
okay a true mathematical point what's
the point a zero dimensional location
nothing that's what a zero that's what a
zero size true point mathematical point
is okay matter collapses literally two
point okay not a pinhead size or any
size but a literal point zero Y zero hi
zero deep now I don't know if you
understand maybe maybe I'm wrong I don't
know maybe I'm miss reading all these
people these are all pH days they're
telling you it's got no no with no
height no no death no another is Minnie
no length okay it's got no dimensions
and it's zero size I don't know and the
other guys tell you all batteries
crushed out of existence so we have a
surface which is the event horizon it's
a surface of what what is it enclosing
whoo what's it what is it imprison you
know what is it constraining okay we
cannot imagine such a thing no kiddin no
no I can't visualize nothing I can
visualize you know dog a cat a rock a
house I cannot visualize nothing
absolutely nothing because there's
nothing to visualize you have no shape
to visualize and he says we can imagine
such a thing but physics says that it is
what happens
well not physical physics okay and that
is a black hole matter that is so dense
it is no longer matter in any real sense
I hope I'm reading all this right okay
I'm getting this from from PhDs here
right physics but some kind of
singularity or anomaly in space okay now
you tell me if if I'm if I'm putting
words in their mouth and my miss reading
something please tell me I want to know
if I'm making a mistake I really do you
know but this is how I interpret this no
dimensions crushed out of it all matter
crushed out of existence only mass only
gravity which is nothing these are two
concepts so they're saying there's pull
of gravity but there's nothing pulling
it's like you know you're pulling on a
donkey but there's no one pulling on the
rope that's pulling on the donkey it's
just the Rope pulling on the donkey it's
not even a rope because there's nothing
there so it's you're pulling on a donkey
without anything okay okay and here just
in case I mean morale
how much more authority do you want then
good old mr. Stephen Hawking died a
couple years ago well this is what he
said I mentioned this in a past but I
thought I'd put it in today for padding
we need all the authority we can get
here right to make sure
Chandrasekhar calculated that a coach
and a seconder was an Indian guy that
came from India to England he studied
and worked there for a while he came up
with a notion of black hole or he he
expanded upon it okay he said there are
real black holes okay I'll get that to
that in a minute
Chandrasekhar calculated that a cold
star of more than about one and a half
times the mass of the Sun would not be
able to support itself against its own
gravity okay Chandrasekhar limit that's
what it's called it's a limit as this
fella pointed out
related to mass no problem there we
don't care because mass has nothing to
do with physics physics we deal with
structure with architecture we deal
first and foremost with objects so if
there's no object we don't care what the
masses can't because it's not applicable
in any ways
Eddy Tong refuse to believe Chandra
cycles result what was it that Eddington
had a problem with by the way he had it
for the rest of his life okay he died
not accepting Chandra seculars
insinuation that there you know that
there is such a thing as a black hole
okay any thought it was simply not
possible that a star could collapse to a
point what is a point a location what is
a location a zero dimensional nothing
it's a concept where you're supposed to
put something in order for it to be a
location in other words not a location
okay you gotta put something in that
location and sent himself oh he said
nothing that was simply not possible a
starkly collapsible point okay Einstein
himself wrote a paper in which he
claimed that stars would not shrink to
zero size we're talking about zero size
location no dimensions what part does
this fellow not understand okay so no
we're not talking about a ball we're
talking about a nothing it's known as
nothing not a ball okay a ball is not
the same thing as nothing yeah let's
make sure we understand that
Paul has shaped nothing has no shape
okay when he was awarded Nobel Prize in
1983 it was for his early work on the
limiting mass of cold stars
Chandrasekhar had shown that the
exclusion principle could not halt the
collapse of a star more massive than the
Chandrasekhar limit hey now how much
more now 30 do you need them man Stephen
Hawking he's on my side he says look we
have this zero dimensional nothing out
there called the black hole he's saying
it's not a ball and it's not a black
ball it's those people who misrepresent
because they're they have mental
problems and they say no it's a ball no
it's not a ball all these people are
telling you it's a zero-dimensional
nothing no structure matter crushed out
of existence no dimensions no size no
nothing okay so don't tell me it's a
ball yeah I want to make sure we destroy
this notion of a ball okay for anyone
who brings it up here and this in this
form at least okay and here's
Chandrasekhar himself the good man what
do you say well this is from his paper
1931 paper in which gave him eventually
his Nobel Prize and you can see the are
there are someone that's the radius and
he says it goes to zero while density
the row under the right hand side of
that goes to infinity and he repeats
that again later on radius is equal to 0
and Rho the density goes to infinity so
here we have all kinds of Authority
behind this ok it's not that I'm
inventing this stuff I'm putting words
in people's mouths
specially into the Mathemagician smiles
these are them themselves talking okay
you don't like it because it destroys
your religion I'm sorry
but this is your your own gurus those
who believe in black holes this is your
own gurus talking they're saying there's
no such thing as a black hole thing
think meaning that which has shape okay
this is not a three dimensional ball
it's a zero dimensional singularity
which is a zero dimensional nothing and
just in case an after Chandrasekhar came
out here we have a paper from this
fellow
and he's uh also Indian he says he
working at Cambridge he came after
Chandrasekhar he is still alive today
obviously I'm solving the equation with
a particular value Rho sub C sub C of
central density you will get a model of
a star with mass m and radius R damn I
understand so far mass M radius R plot R
as a function of M and show that zero
zero
rarh meaning radius right as a function
of M right mass and show that are false
to 0 when M is equal to the
Chandrasekhar mass R goes to 0 ok if you
can do these then you have repeated the
calculation for which Chandrasekhar won
the Nobel Prize they were part does this
bow not understand a black hole has zero
radius the singularity okay
it's a pinpoint nothing that's got
infinite density because it's got all
this infinite mass in no volume that's
why it's infinite so one goes to
infinity the lying down and the other
guy goes to zero what part does he not
understand
he thinks it's a black ball and all
these people think it's a black boss not
only him jfg also thought it was a black
ball everybody has this idea that it's a
black ball so the mathematicians are
getting away with murder when they say
oh it's a black ball and everybody says
ok I understand that because if they
said look it's arrow that mentioned
there's nothing there but it's got
infinite mass well a lot of people would
start questioning that but if they say
it's a black ball everybody said ok that
sounds reasonable
just compress matter and weighs the
light that's the only notion people have
a black hole
that's about as complicated as a black
hole gets here we have another one and
I'm gonna insist on all kinds of
authority here because that's what
people need people need our 30 to tell
them that there's no such thing as a
black hole now this one is interesting
because this came after Chandrasekhar
and this group of people proved again
that yes indeed a black hole is zero
dimensional no
sighs no dimensions no radius no
diameter no nothing okay and here it is
this is the Arctic okay and your ego
went like this says a point of infinite
density and space-time curvature known
as a singularity okay and usually found
at the center of black hole okay can
also exist in a naked form without it's
black hole what is a naked singularity
I'll get to that in a minute but just
for your information for those of you
who don't know what a naked singularity
is it means a singularity that does not
have its event horizon there is no
sphere of influence surrounding a naked
singularity if all it is is just a
singularity and what was the singularity
it was a location on location that has
what in it it has mass gravity here who
knows what may be angels but for sure it
doesn't have any structure no
architecture no body in that location so
it's the center of mass of nothing okay
let's let's make sure we understand that
okay says learn Leonard
together with France Pretorius of
Princeton University showed that at the
point where a smaller black hole pinches
off from the strain the black hole's
radius is zero now what part of zero
don't you understand which means that
its density is infinite again and the
only way it can be infinite if you have
zero volume I hope this is clear I don't
know people who know a little bit of
math I'm sure will understand this okay
in other words it is a naked singularity
Kip Thorne was in the audience and said
the study was beautiful work and Kip
Thorne I mean he's he's a Nobel Prize
winner as well so I mean Jesus oh you
got a lot about 30 here saying look you
know have nothing there okay and here's
the paper they were referring to
yeah from Leonard and Pretorius and this
is what they say in their paper okay
says the simulation results imply that
the string segments will reach zero
radius in finite asymptotic time whence
the classical space-time terminates in a
naked singularity that's what they say
in their paper so what the hell is a
naked singularity
okay let's put it up here so we are all
on the same page okay and here they say
the following this is out of the wiki
okay in general relativity a naked
singularity is a hypothetical
gravitational singularity the location
center of mass whatever without an event
horizon
I like the nest statement that I read
there or the couple of paragraphs down
says from concepts drawn from rotating
black holes it is shown that a
singularity spinning rapidly bla bla bla
bla bla so here we have a naked
singularity which is a location without
body and in without any event horizon
sphere of influence and it's nothing is
spinning so yeah you get all this word
wizardry from the mathematicians because
they can get away with anything I mean
you know and when I was working as an
engineer at a of B I had to produce
results you don't produce results the
the engineering manager you'll hear his
voice the voice of wisdom but these guys
easily I can say anything they want they
can talk about angels people will just
believe them on the basis of authority
well he's a PhD steady ten years he must
know somebody must write okay so uh
here's another comment and that's the
final comment this guy made I love it
because it was a pretty good ending it
says there's still a lot we don't know
about black holes and most of the fun of
science is in the discovery what a
mental case I mean no no science is not
about discovery science is about
explaining ok anybody can go and
discover discover what discover God I
mean what do you guys discover angels I
mean you know a lot of people find these
these discoveries you know they go out
there and they say oh yeah discover God
ok so great you know so no it's not a
process science is explaining ok
and so in as far as black holes we know
everything there is to know about a
black hole there is nothing more you
need to know about a stupid black hole
black hole is simply a star that
collapsed them nothing now
what they're saying and that although
the gravity or the mass remained behind
but the elephant was gone okay there's
no structure that's it what more do you
need to know about a black hole what is
it that that is so you know
mind-boggling about a black hole it's
very clear it's just says that although
mass whatever mass is right because
that's another issue but all the mass of
a son of a star collapsed to nothing and
what you have is a location called a
region known as a singularity center of
mass of what of nothing it's got this
region of influence that moves stars
around far away who knows by what
mechanism because that's the other issue
how does you know a singularity because
even if we concede mass infinite mass
whatever you want I don't care
okay so you got mass guy infinite mass
and if you want a black ball give you
the black ball - the question is now how
does that black ball mass whatever you
want to call it how does it move a star
far away that's what I want to know okay
and what they say well it weighs down
the canvas of space-time and the other
guy falls in that's a two-dimensional
vision of so-called four-dimensional
space-time and I've discussed that at
laws knows him in the past so yeah it's
a totally [ __ ] mentally [ __ ] for
people who have mental problems who have
lost touch with reality they're no
longer in touch they don't no longer
have their feet on the ground okay
that's the problem okay here other
issues
another issue was brought up another
comment oh no sorry this is again the
picture that they took of a
zero-dimensional black hole okay and you
say well if it's there that meant or
what I'm staring at at least two
dimensions they're right at least and
you have to think of that as three
dimensional as a three dimensional
object now the first issue this picture
was taken by several people over several
days so what you're staring at is a
composite picture that's the first thing
that is not always clear to people they
think that these guys just went through
the telescope and took a snapshot that's
what most people believe
because they don't know how this thing
works but now this was taken through a
composite taken from several
laboratories it was punched into a
computer and they created this image
game so this is not a snapshot that's
the first thing we need to clarify the
second one is well what are we staring
at is that Dartmouth thing in the center
a black hole because that's what people
think they say okay I see the black hole
and said little bald black ball in the
center no that's not the black ball no
that's not the black hole okay because a
black hole is zero dimensional okay
remember and so what they're saying this
is the matter falling into this zero
dimensional you know black hole and the
question is how does matter penetrate
you know real matter how does it
penetrate a zero dimensional nothing how
do you do that I mean how do you sneak
through it you would Vaseline around the
the matter so that it can slip in there
I mean I don't know please explain the
mechanism how does a three-dimensional
atom go through a zero dimensional
nothing location okay so this is the
issue and here is the mechanism that I
was talking about I mean here we have a
turtle that's going around mass okay so
you want to put a ball there put a ball
out of here how does the mass affect the
turtle why does it you know what's the
mechanism how is the turtle affected by
mass that's what I want to understand
these illustrate the mechanism meaning
please fill in the blanks put an object
there so that we can see you know how
the turtle is tied to this word called
mass whatever mass is and in the word
bass obviously and you know I've covered
that in the past but just just to closes
it the argument here you have a circular
argument mathematical physics say a
black hole is made of mass it's not made
of architecture it doesn't have any
object in there it doesn't have any
matter because it's been crushed out of
existence
there's no length width or height no
dimensions no sighs no radius okay so
it's just got mass infinite mass okay
will concede so it's got infinite mass
it turns out that you no matter the mass
is the quantity of matter that's what
most people understand by mass and then
they tell you that all matter
crushed out of existence that there's
nothing there so we got a circular
argument there because we have black
hole is made of mass that's all it has
okay at least a non-rotating black hole
one and has no charge you know etc okay
but all it has is mass for sure all
black holes have mass and here we have
you know the mass is the quantity of
matter the notion most people have of
mass and here it says that all mass is
crushed out of all matter is crushed out
of existence so even if mass where the
quantity of matter we have a we have no
mass because you crushed all matter you
got rid of the elephant now you have no
mass you know you only have six tons
what does that mean you know what sense
can that mean and and then you know just
to top it off we have always the good
girls of mathematics I'll put it
side-by-side here and that's Edwin
Taylor and John Wheeler those who don't
know John Wheeler or not into
mathematical physics at all because he's
a very famous guy died already and he
says nature does not offer us any
concept as the amount of matter
history has struck down every proposal
to define such a term even if we could
count number of atoms or by any other
counting method try to evaluate amount
of matter that number would not equal
mass so this stuff that they teach you
in high school that masses the quantity
of matter that's BS okay mass is not the
quantity of matter fact the Wikipedia
mentions that there are seven different
types of notions seven different notions
of mass and when you go to the physics
faq run by the University of Riverside
mr. John Baez you know he tells you his
group tells you there that you have at
least two what is a inertial mass and
the other one is or rest mass and you
have the other one which is relativistic
mass what is relativistic mass what it
means that it depends on speed so how
does the quantity of matter depend on
speed so yeah we got a problem because
then that relativistic mass has nothing
to do with the mass that good ole Newton
dealt with you know for
hundred years ago so yeah mass has
suffered a transformation I'm trying to
tremendous transformation okay okay so
here let's get to the other comment now
yeah I will well get it in here okay
this is one fellow who says so distance
dot does not apply to vacuum and nothing
I don't know what he's actually talking
about all I can do is answer his
question the way he phrased it and so
here's my reply to that let me get that
up here and no there is no separation
between vacuum and nothing so you know
I'm not sure what he meant by that but
I'm just answering his question if he's
saying that the distance referred to
vacuum inand nothing no there is no
distance between vacuum and nothing and
here just in case just too close today I
put this little thingy here this little
graph or this this little chart says
distance is what lies between lengths
okay that's what I would say distance is
the separation between two objects you
have to have an object you can't do it
between vacuum and nothing okay and so
you know again what we have to do is
clarify the question because otherwise
it makes no sense yeah you know you
can't just put a quick notion in there
and say well you know it doesn't
distance apply to vacuum and nothing
well I don't know vacuum nothing our
synonyms and there is no distance
between them because they're the same
thing and it means there's nothing
absolutely nothing in that space your
space is the same thing as vacuum and
nothing okay with that I hope to see you
on Wednesday and what I'm gonna try to
do is get back to the existence of time
does time exists well we'll deal with
that on Wednesday we'll see you that